[Music]
announced it twice tonight calling you
the greatest bend in the world this many
people think oh that's a funny joke yeah
but it's not a joke is it well in the
beginning when we started off like 12
years ago when we start out I think it
was actually 18
it was a joke kind of you know we we had
the song the greatest song in the world
tributes but in the back of our minds we
always sort of thought we're not really
joking we really think we are the best
banner and now there's no question about
it were the best bet you are now it's
just become its own it's also it's
imbued you with special powers both of
you yeah really clear when you watch the
two of you perform it's clear that
you're you're more than human well I
don't know you don't you don't think
you're the best man in the world then
you should just disband why are you even
doing a band yeah I don't want to see a
band that thinks they're pretty good
right or second-best yeah who wants to
pay good money to see that
we want to be up here at the deputy
tippity-top it's not quite the top
little higher but I'm curious you have a
signature move jack the mini tiger roll
whoa why yeah oh did I say something I
shouldn't have said I just it's it's not
something I do anymore but I used to do
a mini tiger roll in the set and it's
basically like a it's something I
learned in judo when I was a teenager
and I brought it to the rock and it was
exciting it's like the power slide or
any of your more powerful rock moves but
I don't do it anymore because uh you
know I'm you know when you when you're
mature you leave some things behind it
sounds like people really want to see
the mini
[Applause]
no listen
here's the thing you remember when
Michael Jordan won those three
championships and then he went and
played baseball and then he came back
and he was older and he won three more
championships but he didn't have to lift
quite as much it was an Air Jordan as
much he was more like jump shooter
Jordan that's me
I don't do the tiger role but you still
I still win the championships of rock
will you do the tiger role for this much
money right here and just just pretend
that's real yes this I got it all right
where do you want
this is good she looks like a gentleman
okay so pretend like I'm rocking really
hard and
[Applause]
oh is that popping noise yeah and why is
there blood on the rug you know there's
not just sweat and spit there's also
some blood semen now you have it I
understand that you guys are gonna
perform a song later in the show I've
been told this by some of my best people
yeah and I got a look at your set you
have an inflatable Phoenix it's a
Phoenix yeah what do you mean what do
you mean it's a Phoenix yeah it's a
penis honey I saw it at rehearsal
oh I on the screen and let's take a look
at the end we'll talk about it because
I'm just curious this is
[Applause]
fiery bird admit it represents rebirth
and like it's so a new dawn of a fiery
bird yeah having aren't you up on your
Greek myths in mythology it's about
rebirth and the dog I know what the
Phoenix is saw that what's most
impressive is its powerful haunches it's
got very powerful leg muscles and you're
not helping you're sorry you're not
helping at all